Bruno Mars if you listen his lyrics
sometimes you're like oh yeah it's
almost like when you listen to the
weekend [__] like you really listen and
you're like
oh the weekend might have a drug problem
I love that though the weekend's my
favorite probably my favorite like I
mean I just love I don't know if I
listen to anyone more than the weekend
I love the weekend he's amazing did you
see him at a sofa no but she did it was
[__] fire really I went the night
before he didn't perform because he
would you know he came out on stage and
like apologized to everybody because his
voice wasn't you know oh no which I
actually liked because most people would
have just pushed through but he was like
nah I gotta do this the right way we're
in LA but he's amazing damn did he come
in like he spin yeah he redid it like a
few I think I think it was like a month
and a half or two later